okay uh let's start uh
today the first talk is uh given by uh
hitler
uh he's going to talk about the official
classic of simulations
and uh we've learned a lot of confidence
but also we've got a classical
gravity so but this is semi-classical
many particles
maybe
all right
thanks again so i'll start by thanking
the organizers frank and matthew for the
invitation to come and give this thought
for organizing the workshop as well
and
yes i want to talk about efficient
classical simulation
of quantum mini body systems with local
intervals of motion that's the longest
title i could come up with
and this is work
that came out of discussions with anusha
chandran and isaac kim to postdocs
perimeter and also dima avanin
and
and maybe i want to start by saying that
there is a physics motivation for this
talk but i'll quickly forget about
physics
so the physics motivation
oops
is is
many body
many body localization
and so for those of you who
who are not familiar with the subject
this is about the
disorder quantum phase of or phase of
quantum matter
um
that um
where there is this localization going
on that means there are
there is no transport
um
that means for us that the state the
whole spectrum
of of the hamiltonian is made of
states that that are almost a product
state
okay
and and then there is a long history
but
i feel very lucky because bella bella
bella bella will give a talk tomorrow
about probably including some physics so
you will learn about the you know
i don't know electrons and things
so um
but let me say then that that there is a
long history of of localization so this
this goes back to
phil anderson
in 1958 and what
what this
work started was
was single particle
localization and so the observation
there was that if you have a system of
free thermians with some local
hamiltonian and you introduce some
random magnetic field you can
you can end up in in in a phase where
all the single particle with functions
are localized in space okay so um if you
have a translation invariant system then
you have a band structure and you have
that eigenstates of the hamiltonian are
spread all over
the system but if you have localization
on the level of single particle then
single particle wave functions um
cannot move or are localized within some
region of space and then you build a
whole spectrum in this case by just the
usual free fermion construction
so so you end up with a spectrum where
which is made of the bases is just
single particle wave functions that are
localized now many body localization is
the interactive version of this so what
you do is you try to understand whether
when you
add interactions to your hamiltonian so
when you go beyond three fermions well
you still have such type of structure in
in the spectrum of the hamiltonian
whether your your states are localized
in some sense and
you know here it's it's a good place to
say what sense this is this would be
whether all the again states of
hamiltonian are
short-range correlated
close to products there can be deformed
to a product state that would be in
absence of topological order then you
can superpose this with topological
order
but i won't go there i'll assume that we
don't have topological order here
all right um and i want to mention that
there are a lot of people who have
worked on this this many body
localization and that roughly started
around 2005 or six
i learned a word last night rekindle i
i don't i forgot that meaning but
the sentence was that many body not the
interest in localization
rekindled
um around this 2006
because there were observation that
maybe if you add interactions you still
keep localization
and since then there have been many
people contributing to that and
i was shocked how many people are here
today so i made a list of the ones that
are here
then i realized they are recording this
so i apologize uh for all people i'm
missing but of course we have bella
bauer who will talk about this more
seriously tomorrow
um
then uh frank pullman might be this is
like checking who is here right so frank
frank okay
all right so local people like joel
moore um brian brian brian brian
right so brian has worked on that as
well thomas prossen thomas yes
hey yeah
okay
and well and many other people so sorry
if i forgot somebody but uh
and and i've been working on this yeah
for the last two weeks
so so
so one thing i noticed with discussions
with anusha and isaac and dima
at perimeter is that that all the work
that has done so far most of the work
that has done so far at least most of it
is using exact diagonalization right and
and so in this type of problems we don't
want to work to work or study the ground
state we want to study the full spectrum
okay so we we cannot use
um
simple
how they call this uh
you you have to to study the whole
silver space right so you cannot say you
study 30 spins
um
right you you have to you you cannot um
use um
line shows or or some simply so it's not
enough to describe one wave function you
want to describe two to the n-wave
functions in a spin system okay and so
this means that the system sizes that
you can study with exactly organization
are rather small say 10 12 14 and you
you start getting tired
um pretty soon
so so what i would like to do in this
talk is to explore
the possible use of tensor networks to
study these problems okay
that's a there's a issue about whether
guan state have a local engineer that's
a issue
uh because you talk about maybe the
uh any eigen states
it's like a product no i'm gonna assume
i'm gonna assume that all of them i'm
gonna assume actually
all of them i'm going to assume that
we're in energy but including guano
states then obviously
including ground state i see so so
whether there's no shenanigans if you
only get a ground state you say oh this
grants it looks like products like
that's localized or maybe such a notion
don't exist
i wouldn't say that you are in a
localized phase if only the ground state
is a product state because
um
then the excited states may be
completely
so so this localization is related to
lack of transport in the system yeah and
if only the ground state is so basically
the question does that
if you only know ground state exactly
can you say something about whether low
energy is manipulated localized or not
many body localized
um you might
um
i don't know the answer
but but this is this so i'm gonna i'm
gonna go with a very very specific
question to bring it to make it um yeah
well defining enough
and it's not going to be this one so so
what do i want to deal with here
so we're going to have a lattice
in the dimensions
and we'll have n sides
and each side is going to be
the level
and so the total silver space
turn to the potential product of both
sides
and of them
it's going to be a high
square
hyper cubic or
whatever
and and that just to make things
concrete it could be anything else
and so and what we have what we're gonna
have here is is a local hamiltonian
and by local i mean that it's gonna i'm
gonna assume that it attacks so if this
was in two dimensions and is where the
size of our lattice
it's the sum of terms that have some
finite support local
support so i'm i'm not looking at
exponential tails exponentially
suppressed tails or anything like that
and then
and then this hamiltonian in the context
of many body localization they have this
order number of properties but i'm not
going to worry about it i'm not going to
specify it actually what what i'm going
to demand is that it has so local
hamiltonian h
and we want to have
um n a complete set of local
integrals of motion
okay
and so
what do i mean by integrals of motion um
so i'll take care of the local part
later but just to be clear
so
we said that we have
these integrals of motion
i'm gonna
denote them by
z
and some index n and it's going to run
from one
to n
and what
what i mean by intervals of motion is a
set of operators say then that commute
with the hamiltonian and commute among
themselves
okay
so that's that's over in capital the
same like number of the sites yes
i think yes and that's going to be to be
concrete i could change this number make
but i'm going to assume that if each
side is this dimensional i'm even going
to assume
that these guys can be regarded as the
dimensional in some sense so i'm going
to assume
actually that
this integrals of motion
i have each and the eigenvalues
different eigenvalues
and then some projectors
so this is the spectral decomposition
of the um
of these integrals of motion
and this is just notation and i'm just
i'm just going to give you an example so
that i mean this this there is no
difficulty here but let me just give you
a concrete example
so so we could think that we have a
hamiltonian which is just some magnetic
field in the z direction
plus say nearest neighbor or yeah some
sigma z same as couplings
maybe nearest neighbors doesn't really
matter okay so imagine we have this this
hamiltonian then
a set of constant integrals of motion
could be given by
its of this z is just a polymetrics
acting on a different
spin okay
so indeed if you look
right so that
one would be sigma
z
and the first spin identity identity
identity on the rest we could have
z2 it could be
sigma z on the second spin
etc okay so in this case it's a
completely trivial example i just want
to make sure that
that um we're not confused by the
notation so in this case you can easily
check that
every single set comes with a
hamiltonian and that they commute among
themselves this edge so that would be an
example okay
so what i'm doing here
is it's just
having a generic situation these
operators don't have to be localized it
could be acting on the whole killer
space of the end spins
um
and this is just the spectral
decomposition
okay
is that clear
so you could you could equally well it
just to satisf the the projections
themselves are intervals of motion is
that right in the individual yes that's
right um but i i like to so the
eigenvalues actually don't don't mean
anything here
but what i'm insisting is that that we
group them in groups of six or d in
groups of t
right so these projectors that you're
mentioning here i'm just putting them
together
when we try to
we consider which is what i'll do now
when you can see local integrals of mod
of of motion then i'll insist that this
all these projectors these d projectors
associated to z to a given integral of
motion they are all acting on the same
region
do you have a particular criteria for
the independence of the intervals of
motion
um
they have right so i want this to be a
complete set
um and so if you can parameters they
have to be independent in order to be
complete
is that what you're asking
well for instance if you just multiply
two of them fine
you can do that
yes this is an algebra right so so so
they form an algebra if you multiply two
of them if you add two of them
if you multiply one times three they are
all intervals of motion so what you want
to make sure is that your set is
complete and this implies that these
guys are independent as well
but i guess you want to exclude
something like that like the projectors
on the icon makers no
because that's obviously a complete set
of particular motion
i mean this is all obvious i'm just
giving you time to get used to the
notation
and when you do insult me a lot better
i'm not sure what you mean by localities
so we have a d here
which is the dimension of the so we have
n sides each side is available system
out and just for continuous here i'm
gonna assume that the intervals of
motion are also d-level
right so so each each of them
um can be expressed as
d different projectors
so if you look at this as an operator i
think on one side then it has two
different eigen values but
the rank is well there are only two
different eigenvectors but if you
multiply times the identity then
degeneracy
okay do you have a situation where
integral motion number of integral
motions much less than the number of
lines inside
um
so here is uh about the same no no i'm
assuming it's a complete set i think so
i'm assuming it's the same
and and you can do like many of these
things i'm just trying to go for the
simplest scenario
okay all right perfect so
locality so
oh no before that um
so i'm gonna insist that this is a
complete set
of integrals of motion and in particular
what that means is that that if we look
at the hamiltonian
then we can find a complete basis a
complete set of eigenvectors of the
hamiltonian
that correspond so i'm going to use mu
here
as a vector with mu 1
mu 2
mu n
this this vector chooses for each
integral of motion it chooses
one option right in this sum
so it's a choice of eigenvalue if you
want for each integral of motion so i'm
gonna choose one
eigenvalue for each integral of motion
i'll make a vector with those and and
then what i'm saying is that you can
characterize every eigenvector of the
hamiltonian
with a string of of muse okay
so you can completely characterize an
eigenvector of the hamiltonian by
specifying
we also have that um
so what what do we have we have
that z
the integral of motion n on
this eigenvector of the hamiltonian is
equal to the corresponding eigenvalue
mu n
mu
okay so c's are different there's no
translation
all cis yeah um
um
this was just an example to to
really completely clarify what these
integrals of motion are this is not an
example of many body localization it
could be but i'm not right so so let's
not worry about whether this is a
disorder or not
okay and all i'm saying is is the
trivial statement that if if or if you
when it follows from completeness of
this complete set of integrals of motion
that you can characterize you can
completely characterize the eigenstates
of the hamiltonian by specifying how
they react
how they relate to to the integrals of
motion all right
excellent so so in this in this example
here that would mean that all the you
all every eigen state of h
is just a product state in the z basis
right and so
again state of h is just a string of abs
and downs
and and this actually
this thing here up or down is giving you
the eigenvalue for for these integrals
of motion so um
well yes so so this should be clear
at this point
all right
so
so then let me just say the same again
i'm gonna say i'm gonna define some
projector
p mu
as the product over all the integrals of
motion
of some
of these projectors
so for each integral of motion
right this is this is
p1 mu1
p2
e2 the order doesn't matter these
projectors commute
etc
right so i'm gonna i'm gonna define this
projector which is for each integral of
motion i give a particular record value
okay and this this by my construction
this is nothing but the projector onto
an eigen state of the hamiltonian
okay
all right so so now let's make this
local okay now the statement that these
intervals of motion should be local what
does this mean
so i'm just gonna
demand
some local
integrals of motion
i'm just going to assume that that each
of these integrals of motion
can be written
i'm just i don't want to introduce more
notation so i'm just going to say that
one thing is equal to itself times the
identity on many sides
okay so so i'm gonna say that each
of the integrals of motion only is
always not trivially supported on
on eta set sites
like long tails
no no no i know so right so so
i'm gonna assume that this is a
hypercube
actually that's not even like this
so um
so i'm going to assume that each
integral of motion is supported on some
finite region
say in this case
this is it a z
beta z
for it is that equal to two okay
so in general we'll have it a z
to the d
sides right so so these intervals of
motion are really
very local
okay
and i'm not going to assume i'm not
going to even allow for exponential
tails deviating from that so i'm just
looking at a very very simple scenario
the exponential tails on top of that so
in many body localization what what the
physics seems to tell us is that that
this this integrals of motion are
essentially contained in a small region
but then there might be exponential
tails i'm not i'm going to cut those
okay
but but one can argue that that should
not be a big thing
if that was an approximation
all right so so so this is the scenario
i want to deal with i want i have this
hamiltonian
it commutes with all these integrals of
motion which happen to be local
and the question
i would like to to ask and try to answer
is a very simple one
so
so if somebody gives you
or given this complete set of local
integrals of motion
can we efficiently classically simulate
this system and of course if i don't say
what i mean by efficiently classically
simulate the system then
that doesn't mean much but
i'll specify that in a bit but i mean
things like can i compute
local expectation values can i
efficiently classically compute local
expectation values for
um for any egg instead of the
hamiltonian this type of questions okay
i'll specify a bit more later on what i
mean by this
um
and and then
i was preparing these notes and i wasn't
sure whether this was a theorem or a
conjecture
but i i know you don't care
i mean yeah
so i actually it ended up being
something um more of a wish
but and and actually
um so so sorry so the question is can we
classically simulate the system
and so the theorem conjecture which is
that yes of course
sure
okay
because you know vladimir this is
integrable at the very least or you know
it's right how many
a complete set
yes
so the intuition is that everything is
determined everything is local so
yeah why what and so the proof
first i started with my hands right you
also know what that is
and and i was at the level of theorem
then uh
and it was still sure
and then um i tried to write something
down and you know we slowed down a
little bit it's a conjecture
and then uh soon
well actually i don't know how to prove
this
so i don't i
i don't know if it's true actually
but
um but then tensor networks came to the
rescue so so let me
let me make a small table of results
so
i'll talk about the spectral
tensor network
i'll talk about whether we can compute
expectation values
for local operators on any eigenstate of
the hamiltonian
and i i could
probably i won't have time of doing
anything but
there is maybe i can announce that you
can also consider simulating time
evolution
on this hamiltonian
starting from an initial state
which is anything that you can
efficiently represent with a tensor
network
okay
so we we start with a tensor network and
we can
and so and and so the the question i
want to address is whether i can
efficiently simulate time evolution what
about just writing down an eigen
function
yes so that's going to be here and the
answer is going to be yes for
yeah
that is
well it's a theorem
yes and i'll draw the the proof
um
so so so then we what i want to do is is
to try to look at this
in one dimension
and in two or three dimensions or any
number of dimensions larger than one
and
and so the good news is that
we can find spectral tensor also okay so
what's the spectral tensor network so i
i'm borrowing this this this label this
name from work by andy ferris who
recently showed that
um you can build a tensor network for
free fermions for a system of
pre-fermions for the whole spectrum
efficiently contractable tensor neighbor
for preference and so so the idea here
is to have a tensor network that can
efficiently represent the whole spectrum
of the hamiltonian right so any
eigenstate of the hamiltonian is is a
particular case of fixing some indices
in this tensor network
okay so we will build this
um spectral
it turns out that in one day you can
build this spectral mps and you'll see
it's piece of cake
and this will be some tensor network
that represents
any projector
onto any eigenstate of the hamiltonian
so basically
it will this tensor nail comes with
extra indices corresponding to the muse
right and every time you fix the muse
you get
a matrix product operator for for this
projector
and you can do the same for for two
dimensions so you can have a spectral
peps in that case
okay
so
it's good news you can efficiently
represent all these wave functions
all of them
two to the n or d to the n in this case
um now
we know in terms of networks that one
thing is whether you can write something
as a tensor network and a completely
different question or much harder in
general is to to efficiently compute
expectation values
okay
from it so so suppose we have this
spectral matrix product state now we can
ask the question can we efficiently
compute expectation values from it and
the good news is is that yes in 1d
that's not going to be a problem and
that's going to be an exact calculation
you can do it exactly
okay with the cost that is proportional
to the system size only
and and time evolution
so again in 1d we can do this we will be
able to do that but this requires
sampling
um sampling over the
the distribution of
there will be some sampling so so we can
efficiently sample
to to find to to evaluate things like
the expectation value
on say a local operator
after some time
yes the the only assumption here is that
this can be represented efficiently with
an nps and the rest is taken care of
taken care of in one dimension of course
so we'll have actually very nice
perfect sampling strategy so you can
draw
it's it's it's a situation where you
sample you have to sample you have to
use monte carlo sampling techniques but
every time you draw a probability
distribution is completely independent
of the previous ones and so all the
samples
right so i'll be sampling over
um
over this this object which is
the overlap between the nps
that is the initial state of this time
evolution
and this spectral
mps
it's a projector right for any value of
mu
mu
mu vector right so this is going to be
the spectral mps and then i can
efficiently sample this defines a
probability distribution and i can
officially sample over that
okay
so what this means is is that that there
are many things you can do and then all
the techniques
all right so no no
i'll get i'll get to that but so i'll
explain that better later but the idea
is that you can always decompose this
state into eigenstates of the
hamiltonian
and this will give you some amplitude
that state psi zero
the an overlap with state e mu
and what you can do then is efficiently
sample
over those amplitudes
right or according to the weight given
by those amplitudes
and and what this does for you it's
quite nice because usually when you do
the time evolution you
you you maybe have to simulate
up to some time and then keep the
simulation after later time here
we we run a sample so we generate
samples and then we can evaluate over
any time that you want so you you could
start with time two thousand and a
million and you still
you will be able to sample that so this
is not time evolution
mps technique it's it's
you can you can directly sample
arbitrarily large times
yes the guys in the middle how do they
look like i mean there's this eigen
state formalization hypothesis that
states if the system is not integrable
that if you're on the bulk of the
spectrum that these expectations should
check the values as if at a maximum
entropy state given or like
global expectation values um that would
not be true here because it's an
integrable system but would they take
the value as the maximum entropy state
given the local constants of motions i
mean can you just easily compute them in
this way can you compute the world sorry
that the expectation values would be
maximum entity states given the local
constants of motion so that's what is an
expectation value that is a maximum i
don't understand it
oh sorry so
you compute these quantities yeah
compare them with the setting where you
would just fix
the
certain maximum energy fixed expectation
values and then they take the maximum
energy state no no no no what i'm saying
is for any vector of the handling i can
compute this value
yeah i mean no but hence in this case
you have a complete set so if it is
known
once you specify all the integrals of
motion you specify the
i haven't applied this kind of system so
i don't know how it's going to look like
oh that's the questions right okay so so
so i have not used this in the context
of many logical qualifications okay
where because i mean i'm assuming that
they have this
um complete set of integrals of motion
and an independent problem which is
something we are working on is how to
determine this complete set right so
here what i'm assuming is that we
already have it
and then given that i'm exploring what
we can do with that
okay
good so so and then the idea is that in
two dimensions you can again build these
spectral pipes for all the whole
spectrum of the hamiltonian but when you
try to compute the expectation values
well if you
you cannot prove that you can do that
efficiently so so you can write the peps
for this expectation value and then you
can
try to use the usual techniques with
peps to efficient but to approximately
contract the tensor network and if that
works then you have a skin
but of course i cannot prove that or i'm
not able to prove that this is gonna
work okay so so the the answer then is
that we don't know what's gonna happen
in here it might be the techniques can
be applied in principle whether they
will work or not um
i
it's something i cannot prove
so you can probably do that the heart of
this though right so
or you know qma i don't know i expected
some fancy name to appear during the
talk but
um
i maybe maybe you can i mean the
restriction here is that this this
integrals of motion are local
and maybe that
allows you to to run away from this but
i don't know
if you take a classical spin glass
right you know something emotional
so this is the perhaps
okay and this is how these types so in a
classical case right so in a classical
case we don't know
even for nearest neighbor or local
hamiltonians that's not known
so even to the classic case would be np
yes so as i was saying
no
i mean this morning i thought oh yeah
all right um
sure i i expected this question at the
end i'm sorry that exists in some cases
you you could build this to be a
spectral mirror oh you mean it already
exists with this i know it's
right the entire spectrum sure um you're
right i have a comment on that but i was
going to get there
in a while all right so
good so
i had a plan
which is time to revise
so
what i'm gonna do um is i'm going to
just mention that if you that you can do
much more than this and that's what i
was trying to do initially okay my the
original theorem was to prove that you
could do everything and in which setting
is that possible so it turns out that if
you have
local a complete set of local integrals
of motion okay these sets
okay if you have a complete set of local
integrals of motion and on top of that
you have a complete set of local
conjugate variables to those
and probably i won't have time to define
this
then
then you can do anything you want in in
any dimension okay efficiently so so you
don't need tensor networks you don't
need anything
so anything you want means that you can
in that case in any dimension you can
compute expectation values of
these expectation values
for
local observables for for any um state
instead of the hamiltonian but you can
even explicitly given a local operator
can explicitly and efficiently
um
uh bill
uh its time evolution
okay
so you can
if you instead if not if you have not
not only local intervals of motion but
complete set also local conjugate
variables to those which i haven't
defined
then basically you have a complete
characterization of
another factorization of your killer
space right so remember we had this this
silver space in terms of size i
so so if you find not just this local
integral of motion but also a complete
set of local conjugate variables then
you can define another factorization
of the sample over space which is
related to this one by some locally
generated unitary
okay
and then you can do many many things
and brian you're looking at me this
would be the one that you describe in
your work
briefly
um if this ads
if this heads
so these heads actually um don't
completely um characterize a tensor
product structure of a helium space
because you have all the
um
they only generate the diagonal part
right so you need
you need some
conjugate variables
that will allow you to move between
the ergon stage of this guy without
touching the rest
of agents of eigenstates right so you
need some some conjugate variables that
commute with the rest of
integrals of motion and only don't
commute with this one and
allow you it's like
creation
sorry
and they have to be local right
so so this this is this is actually
these are the responsible for why we can
we need to resort to tensor networks
here if you don't have those then many
things can go wrong okay all right so so
great so i'm almost done with
introduction and um
let me start so
where's the
okay
in the end there will be some specific
uh constraints on this series
i mean the requirement that everything
should be efficiently simulated by the
network that this requires specific set
of seasons
i'm not i'm not gonna i'm not gonna talk
about the human point
i'm just assuming that this conductor is
such that it has a complete set of
integrals of motion and that's all i
need to do
all right so so
spectral so what's this spectral
tensor network
all right so so
i'm just gonna in one d i'm gonna
specialize to one d
directly i mean this construction is
valid in any dimension but um i'm gonna
assume that we're in one d and
remember i said this guy was local so it
acts as the identity everywhere except
in some
region
and the region has size
ita
with the z
okay
so you can actually write this
this operator in this form okay and and
the assumption here is that this
operator is given to you this four spin
in this case so this is that equal to
four right this is
where it's localized
and so
i i have one thing i have to mention
here is that
that
if you can show it's an easy simple
lemma
if
all
the integrals of motion are local
in the sense that we've set
then there is a finite density
finite
density of such integrals of motion
anywhere so what i mean by this is that
if you look at a particular spin
or particular site of your lattice say
this side here
then there is a finite
number only
independent of the system size of
integrals of motion
that can be acting
non-trivially on that side
okay
and and this is something that you can
argue easily maybe it's even easy to do
in two dimensions so all i'm saying is
that so yeah let's do the
two-dimensional case
so what i'm saying is that that suppose
that
we have a part one
we consider one given site
um in two dimensions
let's say this side here
right what i'm saying is i'm asking the
question how many intervals of motion
have support on that side
okay and and i'm going to assume say
that that each integral of motion
has is supported on ether z equal to two
so it is at square
sides
right and so here's an interval of
motion now here could be another
integral of motion and maybe here we
have two of those no nothing prevents us
from having that situation right but
if you if you look at
how far away from the side we can go
obviously we cannot go too far away so
what i'm saying is all the integrals of
motion that overlap with this
right are contained in a larger
hypercube and this hypercube has size
two
it uh um what was that i said
minus one
times so
you can just check that if you take you
try to place
hyper cubes here or squares in this case
that overlap with this side
then you cannot go too far away from the
side and so so the idea is that we end
up with a region
we can have a look at the region
the region is the region where integrals
of motion containing the region may
overlap with
with
this side
and then
the what we see is that
well how many sides do we have inside
the region so the number of sides q
inside the region is just
two
eta z minus one
square on general d right and so we have
this final region
and now in this final region how many
intervals of motion could we possibly
have that are contained in it remember
that these integrals of motion have to
be independent so at most at most you
can have this number
okay
so you cannot have more intervals of
motion inside
you cannot have more independent
intervals of motion inside the region
than than this number
um because otherwise you would have more
interest of motion degrees of freedom
and so this tells you that
overlapping with the given site you can
have at most this number of integrals of
motion right so and this number is
independent of the system size so what
we learn is that we don't we cannot have
many integrals of motion acting in a
given in any given point okay so so
that's good
that's good because it means that we we
will not have an accumulation anywhere
and so now we are ready to to
to just write the efficient
representation in terms of of a spectral
um matrix product stays in one way
and so i'll do this here
so if i want to represent
a projector
p mu which was
a projector onto an eigen state
of the hamiltonian
then all i need to do is is to
to write
draw lines for all the qubits
and remember each projector is contained
in the support of of of an interval of
motion so the first one
maybe comes here that's just a pictorial
representation you can prove all these
things i'm just trying to give the
the main idea
right so
so what we have is
that the first
projector would go here
the second projector would go here and
there is an extra index mu2 coming out
mu3
u4
okay remember this is nothing but a
product of projectors
each of the integrals of motion right so
i'm just drawing each of those guys
um and each of those
can be represented by some tensor acting
on a small number of spins okay and so i
just keep covering all these
um and when
i get tired down here i continue up here
maybe one more
and the idea is then that you can cover
the whole lattice
and i insist that i'm just assuming that
they are equally spaced that's just a
simplification they don't have to but
there is a final density and that's all
i need
okay so on each on each point i don't
have more than a certain number of
integrals of motion acting on it and so
all i need to do now is for each of
these projectors i just compute
an npo i just decompose it as an mpo
i put it in here
right and i multiply many indices and
after a lot of effort
multiplying these indices
you end up with
some
mpo with extra labels mu1
u2
u3
mu n
and this npo
which has a finite rank here because the
rank is the result of multiplying many
ranks but the final number of those
okay this mpo is is exactly what we were
after okay the spectral nps that we
wanted for for this case so this mpo is
what it's a map
from you know this indices here oh i
promised myself i would use another
color
for those
so we have two types of indices
okay the first the black ones correspond
to spins in our sides in your many body
system and the
red ones correspond to these integrals
of motion okay and this object is for
every time you specify
values for these indices you get a
particular projector into a particular
eigenstate of the handheld
okay
and this you can do it in any dimension
and the only trick is to to remember
that there is a finite density
of integrals of motion once you enforce
they are local
good so
so i'm gonna call this is i'm gonna call
this this spectral nps
and we can do this in two dimensions
we'll get them spectral peps and now
it's a good time to compare this to
things that we already know so for
instance if you give me a toy code okay
the story code is
the hamiltonian is a set of commuting
observables
um and you could take those directly as
integrals of motion right and you can
actually build a peps for the ground
state but actually for
for the whole spectrum of the third code
and this has been done has been used and
it's it's common practice
um maybe the observation here is that
there is a difference between that well
in that case we would have to consider
to talk about topological order but i'm
um the fact that the the
the set of local intervals of motion is
not complete there are non-local
intervals of motion corresponding to the
topological qubits but that's that's not
the point the point that i'm trying to
make is that
in that case we're using a spectral
temps or we could build a spectral
tensor network that would become invalid
as soon as we perturb the hamiltonian a
little bit okay so in the third code in
a fixed point in general in a fixed
point wave function whenever we have a
fixed point of the energy flow
you may have that thus
that
the the spectrum of the hamiltonian is
very degenerate there is no dispersion
relation it's a flat dispersion relation
and this allows you to choose integrals
of motion that are local
okay but this this
disappears as soon as you put the small
magnetic field you put a small magnetic
field the dispersion relation is no
longer flat and then the the
intervals of motion
are no longer local
so so what's interesting about many body
localized phase is that this is this the
presence of inter local intervals of
motion is robust
okay that if you modify your hamiltonian
just a little bit you still have local
intervals of motion so this is not a
artifact of being in a fixed point
rg fixed point uh hamiltonian or wave
function but if i uh in fact i can't
have
these
conservatives which are only local in
this natural sense
but will that violence
so so what i'm discussing here now for
simplicity is the case where they are
strictly contained so if you want is an
approximation where i ignore these
exponential tails i can account for them
at the price so actually this this the
spectral
uh tensor network this spectral nps is
efficient the bond dimension is
efficient
um for if you fix the the
localization the the
right
the range of of the integrals of motion
but it grows exponentially
with the range so so this one index here
grows exponentially
in the
range
of
of this
in terms of motion so if you accept
certain approximation then you can
efficiently compute everything you want
if you want to consider more part of
this exponential tail then you have to
pay exponential price
right the price will grow exponentially
however the good news is that if you
look at
at the simulations in the context of
many body localization the price that
you pay by cutting these tails is that
instead of say a long time
seeing that the entire man grows as a
lock of t it would saturate
but it would take exponentially large
time for you to see that okay so so yes
sure you are you're approximating
something
right but it's it's it's this small
corrections are very long times that you
are going to suppress
okay
good so um
right and another difference with
respect to say the third code where we
would have all these commuting
hamiltonians so the first difference is
in the theory code you introduce a
perturbation you change a little bit
with the hamiltonian you lose this
locality of the intervals of motion in
the many body localized phase you don't
so this is an answer that is um can be
used for the properties of these answers
um
or the designs of exploits are robust in
many body localized phase
and and the other thing is
that the we are not assuming here that
the hamiltonian is is written as a sum
of of per of these integrals of motion
we are not assuming that the hamiltonian
is doesn't have to in the story code the
hamiltonian is just the sum of this
plucket and star term right here we are
not assuming that the hamiltonian is a
sum of these intervals of motion it can
be contained also products of these
integrals of motion arbitrary number of
products
okay so um
well i see that i won't have a lot of
time to do anything else but that's fine
because uh
yeah
um so the the other part i wanted to
discuss is this time evolution
okay and maybe i'll just point out how
you can do this
so the idea is once you have this
oh i have not even discussed that
right so
need to discuss the computation of
expectation values for local observables
but this this now is piece of cake so
what you can do is is simply
what's what would be this what's the
expression
for
the expectation value on a local
operator
for for well this is nothing but the
trace
of p mu
on o
and so pmu is this spectral
guy
with this additional indices
and now we so this this will be premium
with the indices that i'll i'll draw
when i get to the
red
and then here oh it doesn't even need to
be a local observer it could be an mpo
if it can be represented with an npo we
can also plug it in here okay and then
we take the trace
right
and
and so this calculation can always be
this tensor network can always be
computed efficiently
i don't know what that is
um so remember we have extra indices
corresponding to the
news
and every time you specify a mu you can
then efficiently compute this this
tensor network okay so this this is this
is expectation value
and in particular you can use this to
compute the energy or anything you need
to
right so
okay
so so maybe then what i want to mention
is from this spectral tensor network you
can compute other quantities and in
particular time evolution is is is nice
um so for the time evolution
what we want to do
is we have some initial state psi
zero which i'm going to assume that i
can represent as a matrix product state
okay that's my assumption so this
includes products that so in many body
localization a typical numerical
experiment is you start with the product
state and see what happens as you evolve
in time so here we can do that but more
generally the initial state is not going
to be not going to be necessarily a
product state it can be a genetic matrix
product state
and
and so from size 0 then we can
study
what happens when you apply the
hamiltonian
the exponential of the hamiltonian to it
so we time evolve this
and
and in general then we can introduce a
resolution of the identity in terms of
these projectors onto eigenstates of the
hamiltonian so this becomes
sum over mu
so
okay
and the good news is that
we may not know how to compute directly
all this superposition but there is
there are elements in here that we know
how to compute for instance i already
discussed this this thing here is the
energy
right the emu
is the expectation value
of the energy
of the hamiltonian for an egg instead of
the hamiltonian well this this is of the
form that i just discussed right
this is replace o with a hamiltonian
which can be expressed as an npo
so we know how to compute
this guy up here
and the interesting part is that this
defines some weight
this overlap between an egg instead of
the hamiltonian and this generic state
that we represent with an mps
this defines a weight
that we can
efficiently compute
okay how does this work well
this is nothing
but a projector
onto
this guy and then
overlap with
matrix product state
okay and now i just have to draw
something else
similar to what i just did
so
this is going to be
psi zero the mps
then i draw here the projector
onto an egg instead of the hamiltonian
and then
the bra
for the mps right so this is pmu
and as usual or as before
we have these extra indices coming out
mu1
2
mu n
and
what's nice about this this defines a
probability distribution
which we can sample over
okay but it's it's not just a probably
distribution it's actually probably this
a probability distribution so let's
define this as p
of mu
given psi zero
you actually have a matrix product state
form for it right if you contract all
the indices here you end up with just
the muse
and so again you have an efficient
matrix product state representation for
these weights
okay and it turns out that given this
you can actually
you can generate
you can generate probability so you can
generate configurations mu
this is not i'm not explaining this here
but that corresponds to previous work
it's well understood that if you have an
efficient representation for this
probability distribution then you can
generate configurations mu that is you
can generate
eigenstates or choose eigenstates e of
mu with this probability distribution
okay so you can plug all these things
that we knew from tensor networks uh
into this algorithm and you can
efficiently sample
okay at arbitrary times so the idea is
you generate a number of samples
you evaluate some expression but you can
you you imagine you generate l samples
at the cost
each sample is going to cost you order n
okay
system size
and
and you can use these l samples to
evaluate
this this say expectation value of so
you could ask questions about
how much
is
this expectation value for a local
operator
that's a particular question you could
ask
you can use these l samples to evaluate
this at any number of times so so you
can reuse the same samples to
to
follow the whole functions of you know
this is a function of t so
given l samples you can just evaluate
this function at any value t
um
okay great so
this was a bit sketchy but um the idea
is that we can use tensor networks to to
help investigate questions in many body
localization
and the part that i didn't discuss
i was hoping i would not have time
because it's
it's rather involved is the second part
where i said this is all we can do
without conjugate variables but actually
if we have conjugate variables then it
gets more exciting the bad news is we
don't need tensor networks for anything
the good news is well
that that you can um perform all these
tasks efficiently in any dimension
um and without sampling
um
all right so
so how how how could this be useful in
in current efforts in many localization
so so far the status of the field one
one of the things that we are trying to
do in many bodies localization is to
find these integrals of motion that's
there are several authors or several
teams trying to find efficient ways if
you give me the hamiltonian that's right
this is a problem i didn't discuss here
if you give me the hamiltonian can you
find these integrals of motion these
local integrals of motion i have not
dealt with that here so this is an
ongoing
research effort
and
the results what they point out is well
first if you find them
here's what you can do
okay you can do a number of things but
it also draws the attention um to the
fact that
that maybe you don't want to just find
this integral local integrals of motion
but the search should be redirected to
finding not only the local integrals of
motion but also these
um
conjugate variables because um the the
number of the ability to simulate those
systems um then is it's much much larger
okay if we have this integral uh this
conjugate variable as well
okay thanks
a couple of questions first when you
said spectral peps under 2d is that a
matrix product operator and not a
you can think of it as some tensor
network
in two dimensions because it's actually
implementing the projection where if you
so there are two sets of indices one
corresponding to two physical sides
blanket so that would be a peppa or
whatever
and then extra index corresponding to
the different the the different
integrals of
a different set of indices right so
so i don't know how you want to call it
but yeah that would be the object
and then just a separate different
question for the
um
let's see
certain systems presumably you know do
you can you characterize the systems in
addition to being able to simulate them
for things that have local conjugate
variables in the sense that we know
the structure enough to sort of say
these ones will not have local funds
right so i suspect that
one can write some theorem that says
that
a hamiltonian
has
this structure where you can find a
complete set of local intervals of
motion and conjugate variables even only
if there is a quantum finite depth
quantum circuit
that takes this kind of time and brings
it into
the one that um yeah um
they don't have to be so no one that is
expressed a in in the sets directly
right so products of science
so sorry the example i gave before was
sigma sets
so i'm not saying it's a product
hamiltonian it's i'm not saying it's the
sum of just magnetic fields
you can have interactions and at all
orders so it can have
two body terms three body terms
right
so so i suspect that this is a complete
answer
that any
anytime you find a complete set of
local integrals of motion local
conjugate variables then you can
actually
this hamiltonian is coming from
um
taking as a diagonal hamiltonian of the
form i just described and applying a
finite depth quantum circuitry
okay so um the locality
of the integral of motions is only a
sufficient
condition for our things to work right
so
everything was still
defined if we if we can find a system of
our integral uh motion so that in the
spectral
uh
we have a spectral uh mps
right so and and
and which is efficiently contractable
like the tree is being being small
right so what you're doing here is to
ensure
so the locality implies that the path
leads to small
mortality implies efficiency in the
description right and and there are more
general
uh spectral mds that could be
efficiently contracted right for example
perfectly and then the path the only
writer's path maybe
uh the whisper
which is very very large but when you
join as a tree actually it's the
treatment all right so that's that's
bran's question so you could actually
generalize this you could assume that
you can use a three you can use a mirror
so you can you can
combine this idea
with
other tensor networks
yeah so maybe i'm trying to say that
for the question that you said you
didn't have time in school like looking
for uh
local
integral motions maybe there's a broader
question that's done it doesn't need to
be local i agree i mean you can allow
for so if you find that you have some
density of short range integrals of
motion and then
some density of large so every time you
have local intervals of motion
if the conjugate variables are also
present actually then you can
remove those from the description of the
system so there is some energy flow
going on which is not on energies but on
the scale zone on online scale so so you
you can actually once you identify some
local internal motion and conjugate
value
it's like a cubit sitting there asking
to be removed from this here
and if you can do this here is there and
so on then you may be left with a system
that has intervals of motion at the
longer length scale but since you've
removed some of those cubits in between
now this has become sharp so you can you
can have some rg flow or some rgb skin
or some rg construction of this shot
so i'm going to explain why
the last question no
i guess it's supposed to frank and view
i'm not sure that i uh agree with the
statement that this is indeed the hard
simply because that the expectation
value that your estimated estimating is
parameterized by mu not by the
ground state of the hamiltonian right so
what the sense behalf is actually just
to decide whether this perhaps is zero
or not
that's the idea
so i give you these perhaps and the
question is is it zero
and that's empty zero do you mean the
overlap or yes whether they're
compatible with each other
okay i think it's a copy
and uh